ومعنا هنا في الاستديو دكتور لقاء مكي
الباحث الاول بمركز الجزيره للدراسات اهلا
بك دكتور مكي استهداف جديد هذه المره
يتعلق الامر بالمدمر الامريكيه يو اس اس
يفلي كيف تقرا هذا الاستهداف الجديد طبعا
هذه ليست المره الاولى اللي تستهدف فيها
قطعه قطعه عسكريه
امريكيه لكن الاصرار على مهاجمه السفن
العسكريه تحديدا هو نوع من التحدي المباشر
للقوه الامريكيه في الحقيقه لم ترد حتى
الان على استهداف قواتها وهو سابقه من
نوعها حقيقه على مستوى حتى صراع مع دول
اخرى وليس مع حركات او تنظيمات بالتالي
اظن ان مستوى التحدي ارتفع لكن مستوى
الاستجابه الامريكيه مازال منخفض
لاعتبارات
كثيره لا تتعلق فقط بعدم يعني يعني القدره
على ضرب الحوثي لن يؤدي الا الى تدمير في
اليمن اضافي لكن ايضا لعدم توسيع رقعه
الحرب في المطقه وفي الشرق الاوسط وعدم
استهلاك او استنزاف القوه الامريكيه لكن
تقول ان امريكا لم ترد كان هناك استهدافات
في صنعاء وجاءت ردا على ما يجري في البحر
الاحمر هذه الاستهدافات كانت على ما قام
به الحوثي من استهداف للسفن لكن استهداف
القطاعات الامريكيه نفسها هذا يستلزم حرب
يعني هذا ال نوع من اعلان العدوان اعلان
الحرب على امريكا يعني امريكا لم تتعامل
الولايات المتحده لو كان هذا حصل في سياق
مختلف تماما مع دوله مختلفه هذا اعلان حرب
لكن السياق فهمته الولايات المتحده انه
محاوله للجر امريكا الى حرب وطبعا واشنطن
ترفض الدخول في حرب شامله لكن هو سجل نقاط
الحوثي بالنهايه يعني سجل له نقاط ادى
الى تاكيد مصداقيته في امكانيه ضربه لسفن
بالتاكيد مدنيه او تجاريه فاذا كانت
العسكريه تضرب فلماذا التجاريه وبراك مسار
هذه الاستهدافات الى اي
سيتجه حقيقه واضح ان الحوثي لديه اصرار
على الاستمرار بالعمل بهذا الاتجاه لم
يعلن ابدا انه يمكن ان يقلل او يمش او
يحدد من عمله بل حقيقه لم يؤدي حتى الى
تصعيد العمل لمنع السفن كلها ظل مصر على
السفن الاسرائيليه والسفن الامريكيه
والبريطانيه العسكريه وبالتالي هو لديه
رؤيه اعتقد مستمر عليها حتى الضغوط
الايرانيه مثلا لا اعتقد انه ستنفع معه ا
في السابع عشر من فبراير المقبل سيبدا عمل
القوه البحريه الاوروبيه
لحمايه السفن ولن تكون جزء من اي هجمات ضد
الحوثيين لكن وصول هذه القوه الى البحر
الاحمر ما الذي سيضيفه للمشد برايك هو نوع
من التدويل حقيقه صحيح القوه الامريكيه
موجوده توفير الرخاء مع بعض بعض الدول
الاخرى بريطانيا وامريكا بشكل خاص لكن هذا
تدويل اكبر ولا ننسى ان هناك قطع ايرانيه
في المنطقه ايضا ولن يعني لن نستبعد ان
تكون هناك قطع صينيه بالمستقبل لان الصين
مصالحها الجوهريه في هذه المنطقه
الامدادات وال يعني سلاسل الامدادات
الصينيه الى اوروبا والغرب اعتقد ان هذا
تدويل اضافي طبعا اوروبا او السفن هذه كما
قال بوريل لن تستهدف الحوثي لكنها
قد تنزلق وقد تنزلق وقد تضرب ايضا
وبالتالي لا نستبعد انزلاق ا يعني انزلاق
اوروبا ايضا الى هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور لقاء مكي البحث الاول بمركز الجزيره
للدراسات ضيفنا هنا في الاستديو